welcome everyone to part three in our
series on analysis methods in nlp we're
going to be talking about adversarial
training as well as testing of systems
this is the second of the behavioral
evaluation methods that we're
considering we previously talked about
adversarial testing
adversarial training and testing of
course implies that we have a much
larger data set so this is more
difficult to do
but for selected tasks where we have
such data sets this can be very exciting
and push you to address all sorts of
interesting cutting edge questions
i'll start with swag this is an early
entry into the space of adversarial
train sets swag stands for situations
with adversarial generations
there's actually two data sets swag and
the colorfully named hella swag and
you'll see why there are two in a second
this is fundamentally again another
interesting story of very rapid progress
in our field
here's how swag examples work were given
as a system input
a context like he is throwing darts at a
target
and another system input which is the
start of a sentence here it's another
man
and the task of the system is to figure
out what the continuation should be so
the actual continuation that we predict
might be throws a dart at the target
board
and this is fundamentally a
classification task the system is given
some distractors like comes running in
and shoots an arrow at a target or is
shown on the side of men or throws darts
at a disc and the system is tasked with
figuring out which of the options is the
actual continuation for the sentence
given the context
the data sources for this are activity
net and the large scale movie
description challenge i think the idea
here is that we're going to key into all
sorts of interesting notions of common
sense reasoning
now here's where the adversarial part of
this comes in we're going to do
adversarial filtering for swag
for each of the examples in our corpus
and there are over a hundred thousand
examples in swag we're going to be given
the system input like the mixture creams
the butter sugar
and then we'll have a generator model in
the case of swag this was an lstm
produce some distractors for the target
so let's suppose that the actual target
continuation is is added we'd have a
model produced is sweet and is in many
foods
and then we have the filtering model if
it guesses correctly it for is added
then we're going to drop out this entire
example and we'll create some new
distractors like is sprinkled on top or
is in many foods and in this case if the
model guesses incorrectly like suppose
it chooses b in this case then we'll
keep this example because relative to
the current models for the lang the
thing we're using to generate these
distractors and the thing that we're
used to using to filter this is a
challenging example and the idea is that
we can repeat this for a bunch of
iterations continually retraining the
filtering model so that it gets better
and better and therefore ending up with
a data set that is really really
difficult in terms of the current models
that we had available to us
here's a picture of test accuracy this
is kind of interesting here they
actually did an ensemble of filtering
models to try and key into different
notions that might be indicating which
is the correct continuation so they
start by using just a multi-layer
perceptron for efficiency and then they
bring in all of these ensembles and you
can see that test accuracy as we do this
iterative filtering very quickly goes
down so that by iteration 140 we're at
10 accuracy
so that's the sense in which this is a
very difficult data set because given
the generator model and the filtering
model that we have available to us we
have a data set that is very difficult
in terms of a classification task
so that looks really exciting and
challenging and i think the authors
expected this data set to last for a
very long time however the vert paper
the original bert paper did evaluations
on swag and essentially solved the
problems bert large got
86.6 and 86.3 on the devon test sets for
swag respectively a very unexpected
result given that i just showed you that
the swag authors got about 10 with their
current models and even
closely related models to bert like this
e sim model here were really pretty low
in their performance so bert looked like
a real breakthrough and you can see that
it's in some sense kind of superhuman
relative to the swag estimates
so wow so of course we know what the
response should be given that we're
talking essentially about model in the
loop adversarial data set creation that
leads us to hella swag they made some
changes to the data sets that they use
for hella swag but i would say the
fundamental thing is that we do the same
kind of adversarial filtering with a
generator except now we have much more
powerful filtering and generator models
thanks to developments related to
transformers so for heliswag we again
have human performance that's really
good this is very reassuring because we
are using much more powerful models at
step four
as you can expect burt is no longer
easily able to solve this problem
here's a further summary of the results
with burt large before remember that
essentially solves swag now it's down
around 50
which
shows that it still gets traction but is
nothing like the human perform
superhuman performance that we saw for
swag
okay now let's move into a slightly
different mode and this is going to be a
kind of human in the loop adversarial
data set creation method the first entry
in this space was the adversarial nli
data set i think this is a really
visionary and exciting paper
adversarial nli is a direct response to
the previous things that we've seen with
the snli and multi-nli data sets where
models seem to do well on those
benchmarks but are easily susceptible to
simple adversaries with adversarial nli
we're going to hopefully push systems to
be much more robust to those adversaries
and explore a much wider range of the
space of things you might see under the
heading of natural language inference so
here's how it worked
there's a human in the loop an annotator
and the annotator is presented with a
premise sentence and a condition that
they need to be in which is just an nli
label entailment contradiction or
neutral
the annotator writes a hypothesis to go
along with the premise and the condition
and then a state-of-the-art model comes
in and makes a prediction about the
premise hypothesis pair
if the model's prediction matches the
condition that is if the model was
correct then the annotator needs to
return to step two and try again with a
new hypothesis and we could continue in
that loop
if the model was fooled the premise
hypothesis pair is independently
validated by other annotators of course
so what we get out of this is we hope a
data set that is intuitive for humans
because of the check at step five but
assuming we continue to loop around
through two three and four an example
that is really difficult for whatever
model is in the loop
and the expectation is that as we put
better and better models in the loop
here we're going to get even more
challenging data sets as an outcome
nli examples tend to be impressively
complex you can see that this example
has a very long premise the hypothesis
is relatively shorter and an intriguing
aspect of adversarial mli is that
annotators also constructed a reason or
a rationale for their label holding
between the premise hypothesis pair
to date as far as i know relatively
little use has been made of these texts
but i think they could bring in other
aspects of natural language inference
reasoning and that could be an exciting
new direction
adversarial nli is a difficult data set
indeed we have a similar sort of
leaderboard that we've seen throughout
this adversarial regime where
across different rounds of a li there
are three or cumulatively for the data
set even really excellent models that do
really well on snli and multi-nli
are posting really low numbers for all
of these variants of the data set and
that shows you that this is truly a
difficult problem and as far as i know
not much progress has been made uh since
this data set was released on boosting
these numbers
so it stands as an interesting challenge
stepping back here i'd just like to say
that i think we find in this paper a
real vision for future development and
that you see this also in the swag in
helsifying papers as those authors say
this adversarial data set creation is a
path for nlp progress going forward
toward benchmarks that adversarially
co-evolve with evolving state-of-the-art
models right with swag and heliswag we
saw this swag got solved but the
response was clear bring the best model
in and use it to create the successor
data set that stands as a real challenge
you have a similar picture from the
adversarial nli paper this process of
having iterative rounds with humans in
the loop yields a moving post dynamic
target for natural language
understanding systems rather than the
static benchmarks that eventually
saturate and we've seen repeatedly that
our benchmarks saturate very quickly
these days so we need this kind of
moving post to make sure we continue to
make
meaningful progress
the neodoll project gave rise i believe
to this dynabench platform an open
source platform for model and human in
the loop data set creation
there as of this writing there are four
data sets available that have been
created on dynabench an nli data set
which is a kind of successor to a li a
question answering data set a sentiment
data data set and a hate speech data set
so if you're working on problems of this
form or you have a model that would fit
into this mold for one of these tasks i
would encourage you to explore some
training of systems on these data sets
to see whether you're making progress uh
or whether they stand as true
adversaries for whatever innovative
thing you're doing
finally i want to close with a really
important question for this area that
kind of remains open
can adversarial training improve systems
there is a course of concern that as we
construct ever harder data sets we're
pushing systems into stranger parts of
the linguistic and conceptual space
which could actually degrade their real
world performance we have to keep an eye
on that and the evidence so far i think
is pointing to yes as an answer to this
question but the evidence is a bit mixed
so i've mentioned that in the squad
adversarial paper from gia on the on
training on adversarial examples makes
them more remote robust to those
examples but not to simple variants so
it's hardly very much progress
in this paper they found that
adversarial training provided no
additional robustness benefit in the
experiments using the test set despite
the fact that the model achieved near
100 accuracy classifying adversarial
examples included in the train set so
that's a more worrisome picture
but this is more hopeful fine-tuning
with a few adversarial examples improve
systems in some cases especially where
you bring in inoculation and this is
hopeful yet again adversarially
generated paraphrases improve model
robustness to syntactic variation that's
really the dream there that as a result
of doing this new kind of training we
get systems that are truly more robust
but i think we need more evidence on
this picture which means more data sets
of this form and more an interesting use
of the available resources
and i would just love to see what the
emerging picture is over the next year
or two
you